Let's do another example where
we have some data.
We want to fit a line to that
data, and maybe use that to
estimate some of the
data that we didn't
collect, so to speak.
So the first thing they ask us,
let's look at the chart
first of all.
This is birth year.
They started in 1930.
They go all the way up
to the year 2000 in
increments of 10 years.
They tell us the life
expectancy in years.
So a good thing for us.
I think this is the
United States.
The life expectancy has been
steadily increasing.
The first thing they ask us to
do is to make a scatter plot
of the data.
I did this on Excel
ahead of time.
This is what I got.
As you can see in 1930
it was 59.7.
In 1940 it was 62.9.
These blue dots are
just plotting each
of these data points.
1930 is 57.9.
It's that data point
right there.
In 1940 it was 62.9.
It's that data point
right there.
So I just went ahead and
plotted all of them.
Then I let Excel figure out
a line of best fit.
I didn't go into the math
of how to do this.
We'll do that in
future videos.
It's out of the scope of
introductory algebra.
But Excel figured out that the
line of best fit, the line
that is least far away from
all of these points, that
minimizes the distance from all
of these points, is y is
equal to 0.2395x minus 400.99.
I'm not going to go into what
r squared is just yet.
But it's a measure of how good
this line is actually fitting.
So let's use that.
Let's use this table.
Let's use our line of best
fit to answer the
rest of their questions.
So the second question is, use
the line of best fit to
estimate the life expectancy
of a person born in 1955.
So we have two options.
We could just eyeball it.
1955 is right there.
So if you go up from 1955 you're
going to hit the line
of best fit.
Let me do it in different color,
because that's the same
color as the dots.
In 1955 you're going
to hit the line of
best fit right there.
If I were to just eyeball
it, it looks
like it's right there.
This is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So these are increments of 2.
So it looks like
about 77 years.
So 1955, it looks roughly equal
to 77-- no, no sorry--
67 years-- let me be clear, it
sounded suspicious-- a 67 year
life expectancy.
Now we can use the equation of
this line of best fit to come
up with the exact value.
When x is equal to
1955, what is y?
What is the life expectancy
in years?
Let's get our calculator
out for this.
Actually let me use a graphing
calculator for
this one right now.
So let me clear this.
Let me clear everything.
Then let's just punch
in 1955 for x.
So we have 0.2395 times 1955,
that's our x-value, minus
400.99 is equal to 67.23.
So our line of best fit
gives us the exact
answer of 67.23 years.
So our eyeballing it wasn't
that far off.
So that's what our line of best
fit would predict, if we
assume that a linear model
is a good model to
describe this data.
All we know right now are
linear models, so
that's what we'll use.
It actually looks pretty good.
It seems like it fits the data
pretty, pretty good.
Let's do the next part.
Use linear interpolation to
estimate the life expectancy
of a person born in 1955.
Now linear interpolation means
let's take the data points
around 1955.
So you have this data
point from 1950.
You have this data
point from 1960.
Let's draw a line between those
two data points and
assume that the 1955 number
would be right in between on
the line there.
Now we could figure out the
equation of that line.
We have two points.
We have the 1950 data and
we have the 1960 data.
We could figure out the
slope of the line.
We could figure out
its y-intercept.
Then we can substitute
1955 in there.
But this is a line, and
1955 is right in
between these two points.
It's 5 from either one.
So on this point right here,
that's on that linear
interpolation, on that orange,
will just be halfway
between these two.
So we can even average those.
So let's do that.
So if we just average those,
68.2 plus 69.7 is equal, and
then we want to divide it.
That answer means our
previous answer.
So that number divided by
2 is equal to 68.95.
So part 2, through linear
interpolation we get 68.95.
Is that what I got?
68.95, so that is this
point right here.
So linear interpolation is
giving us a slightly higher
estimate than our line of best
fit across all of the data.
You can even eyeball it if you
look at it right there.
Let's do the next one.
Use a line of best fit to
estimate the life expectancy
of a person born in 1976.
Once again, we can use the
equation of the line of best
fit, plug in 1976 here and
see what it gets us.
We can eyeball it.
1975 is there.
1976 is there.
It'll be right around there.
Let's actually use the
actual equation.
So in 1976, this is going to be
the line of best fit, the
line of best fit is going to
give us, if we actually figure
out what this line value gives
us, so we get 0.2395 times
1976 minus 400.99.
So 72.26 years, so it gives
us 72.26 years.
So it equals 72.26.
Let me make this clear here.
These columns, this one right
here, is line of best fit.
This one right here
is interpolation.
Now they want to use linear
interpolation to estimate the
life expectancy of a person
born in 1976.
So what they want us to do is
draw a line between these two
points, and then use that line,
not the whole line of
best fit, to figure out what
1976 might have been.
Now before, 1955 was right in
between those two values.
1976 is not right in between
those values.
So let's actually figure out
the equation of this line
using the points, these two
points, 1970 comma 70.8, and
1980 comma 73.7.
Let's figure out the slope
of that line, of
this line right here.
So the slope is the change
in y over change in x.
It's going to be 73.7
minus 70.8.
That's how much we change in
the y direction, divided by
how much we change in the x
direction, 1980 minus 1970.
So this is going to be equal
to 3.7 minus 0.8 is 2.9.
So it's 2.9 over 10.
So it's equal to 0.29.
We changed 2.9 years in life
expectancy every 10 years over
that time period right there,
or 0.29 per year.
Now what's the equation
of that line?
Well we know that the point 1970
and 70.8 is on that line.
So if we say the equation is y
is equal to mx plus b, we know
that y is equal to 70.8 when--
we know m is 0.29-- when x is
equal to, or when the year
is equal to 1970,
times 1970 plus b.
Now we can calculate
our y-intercept.
So what is our y-intercept?
We'll get our calculator out.
We have to subtract this
from both sides.
So b is equal to 70.8 minus
0.29 times 1970.
Let's get our calculator out.
There we go.
All right, 70.8 minus
0.29 times 1970 is
equal to minus 500.5.
So this is equal to
negative 500.5.
So the equation of our
interpolation line-- remember
we're just finding the equation
of this line between
1970 and 1980-- is, that
equation is y is equal to
0.29x minus 500.5.
Now if we want to figure out
what that line, if we want to
interpolate 1976, we just have
to put 1976 in there for x.
So what is life expectancy
in 1976?
Get our calculator out again.
0.29 times 1976 minus 500.5
is equal to 72.54.
So we get 72.54 is
what happens?
It's the number we get when
we do linear interpolation
between those two data points.
All we did is we figured out
the equation of the line
between those two points.
Then we plugged in the number
1976 to get 72.54.
That's a slightly, slightly
higher number than what the
line of best fit gave us.
But it's pretty, pretty close
in either scenario.
Now let's do this last part.
Use the line of best fit to
estimate the life expectancy
of a person born 2012.
This is what's cool about
the line of best fit.
We don't have 2012 here.
2012 goes off the table.
But we could just keep
continuing on with this line
right here-- now I'm using the
wrong color-- keep continuing
with this line right here and
see what does this line equal
when the year is
equal to 2012?
So all we have to do is put 2012
in for x and we'll get
what the line of best
fits tells us.
We'll get the calculator
out again.
So we have 0.2395
times 2012 minus
400.99 is equal to 80.88.
So this last part, in 2012 if
you were to use a line of best
fit, the average life expectancy
in the U.S. will be
80.88 years.
Anyway, hopefully you found
that to be interesting.
Sometimes dealing with data
can be a little bit hairy.
These aren't nice,
clean numbers.
But it gives you a little sense
of why slope, and y-
intercept, and interpolation,
and fitting a line, is
actually very important to
analyzing data and coming to
conclusions from that data.